Recall our terminology for describing architecture in terms of components,
connectors and configurations. The components are mainly determined by
the system's functionality, with a few invented to handle non,
some non-functional requirements. Now it's time to take a look at connectors.
The main material for this lesson comes from the [UNKNOWN] paper,
which I have asked you to read. There is also some material in
the optional text by Taylor [UNKNOWN] on software architecture foundations.
According to Shaw and Garlan, connectors are responsible for
mediating the interactions among the components. They establish the rules that
govern component interaction and specify any auxiliary mechanisms required.